[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ty tools day whoa whoa new face we got a
new face on the show my boy will will
what's happening welcome to the show how
is your NBA betting going so far
I don't even want to talk about it man I
don't even I ain't hit a parlay yet I
have not hit a part it's been crazy
those are the Vibes you're
like what about your players I know
you're a big player prop guy
oh yeah not come on like the player pops
they hitting but come on the parlays is
where it's at like how I'm gonna turn my
fifty dollars to 500 come on
yeah man we gonna get you right bro we
gonna get you right you gotta tap into
winners only
um and we we will get you right will uh
but we're looking at the bet we invented
the three by two that's two three
pointers in the first three minutes
they're now offering it for every game
will I'm gonna start off with you
actually hold on hold on producer Ryan
what up how did I miss you bro what up
how you feeling today oh I feel pretty
good man as a uh as a Boston Celtics fan
the uh the Brooklyn Nets are are
Lighting on fire so that's always good
for me I love that it's a good day I
don't I don't know about lighting on
fire I think they're getting right and
in fact but producer Ryan since we're on
you look through the three by twos talk
to us which one is catching your eye and
then we'll talk to me which one's
catching your uh so I will say
there is one that I like and it's for
one reason only I love the Magic in the
Thunder 3x2 and it's only because the
yes this is the only one that's yes is
plus money
that that is it I have no analysis I
have no reason I know Paulo bencheros on
on the magic I know he's a bucket but I
see plus money and I say why not
all right
we'll give it to him
hey look man I'm looking at that Suns
and Timberwolves game man for that three
by two definitely because like you got
all those Shooters out there you got cat
you have Cam Johnson Devin Booker
DeAngelo Russell look they're gonna be
it's gonna be a high scoring game so
that three by two should definitely hit
for that matchup
there it is thank you guys for tapping
into the 3x2 but now let's get to the
nitty-gritty let's get to the
nitty-gritty we got you here for a
reason will we got you here for a reason
you wear that lock around your neck for
a reason tell the people
tell the people what that lock represent
bro like when you look like when the
pics start coming out it's locked like
you gotta lock it in you know you got to
go get it before the money line you know
for all those stuff change all the odds
change up so definitely got the lot you
know I have to bring it out for you guys
look man the Lock's heavy as hell but
for you guys I'ma wear it
hey there it is it's it's heavy but my
man is rocking it for the shoulder day
if you don't know now you know that he
is the locksmith and he got he really
will is serious about this he got the
chain will let's get right to it bro
let's get right to it six Best Bets that
you like tonight
we're going to talk about it you're
gonna have 45 seconds on the clock 45
seconds is going to be on the clock
why waste time let's get straight to it
will go yo look man talk to me about
nuts money line that's money line
tonight man now look before today even
started I was I wasn't really sure about
this because Steve Nash was my team's
head coach but let me tell you something
after the day that we had today Steve
Nash is now gone y'all tell you
something right now Greg it's looking
like yo I would probably bet my life
savings on next money line look Kevin
Durant Kyrie Irving had a big game last
night they're gonna be extra motivated
you know I was a bit I'm a little bit
disappointed that my boy Ben Simmons is
not going to be out there because you
already know I was ready to push some
Ben Simmons propaganda well I'll
probably get it down a little later let
me tell you guys something right now
this next team is starting to turn
things around I think that the Chicago
Bulls is playing us at the wrong time
they're going to get a motivated Kevin
Durant a motivated Kyrie Irving look
exactly look he might even be hurt but
look wait bro come on now I can't even I
gotta finish right now because I got
some more stuff to say though I'm not
gonna lie get it out get it out get it
out get out yeah what all I want to say
is this the Bulls is lucky that Ben
Simmons is not playing this is a team
that's gonna be the future NBA champs
and I'm telling you guys right now Ben
Simmons is going to be a big part in
that and I was looking at some of his
props before he got out but I don't even
want to start renting man look let's
just move on though but next money line
for sure definitely
I love the energy I love the energy love
the passion but my man you said some
questionable things in your rant let's
bring in Ryan though because
Ryan talks to the chat and I know Ryan
has a take too so Ryan my man my man get
guaranteed the Nets what's their record
this year the the two and five Brooklyn
Nets I think that's how we should refer
to the moving forward the two and five
Brooklyn Nets and for those wondering
the two that's the amount of wins they
have
will thinks that they're going to the
championship uh what's the chat talking
about what's the what's that what's the
chat talking about they like his pick
tonight or what uh Craig Alfredo says
what's Ben's deal referring to Ben
Simmons uh you got any Scoops Scoops for
us there will
look don't worry about Ben don't worry
about Ben y'all lucky that he's Rusty
that's all I'm saying right yeah he's
explaining he's planner he's not playing
he's out
he's out there it is all right there it
is Greg you know we're always looking
for Scoops so we need we need something
yeah that's all we're looking for is
Scoops that's all we're looking for uh
Darion says Bulls money line uh
uh mole man I have a parlay uh for
tonight Katie and Kyrie 30 each
well you like that
I'm liking that I'm liking that yeah I
would take the highway I would take the
underarmed
hey Kyrie's a bucket getter man you
can't can't don't disrespect Kyrie like
that uh uh my man Rock producer Ryan
he's a bucket getter yeah no no no like
I said again the Celtics fan you don't
stomp on my team's logo and then expect
me to respect you that's just not gonna
happen I saw this news I went on today
and I went to DraftKings or I went to
FanDuel I'm sorry and I placed uh the
Nets to miss the playoffs plus 400.
that's just what happens
hold on hold on producer Ryan we're
sending you back to the chat because uh
unfortunately that
was not a good bet that was a donation
um
will he just came in here and said that
your nets aren't making the playoffs
I don't know about that what I don't
know how you feel about that one but you
gave us one pick you got five more talk
to us what are you leaning with next
I look man we staying on a Brooklyn Nets
KD over six and a half assists look when
Ben Simmons is out Katie is the main
facilitator man also on top of that uh
the Chicago Bulls give up the second
most assists per game I actually have a
number right here they give up 28.7
assists per game so they're gonna be
throwing a lot of looks at KD to slow
him down scoring the ball so you're
definitely gonna have a lot of
opportunities to get it sets you know
he's playing with Kyrie Irving a bunch
of Shooters is on this Brooklyn Nets
team and on top of that you know you got
Claxton down there in the paint so
definitely Katie over 6.5 assists I
think you know he covered that last game
as well he had seven versus paces and
I'm really liking that and I think
that's decent odds there especially for
as much as he's gonna control the ball
because if the building Nets are going
to win this game Katie got to get going
so I expect him to get it done tonight
6.56
there it is my man will just just just
got straight to it Kevin Durant's over
six and a half assists he made his
points no Ben Simmons KD will be the
play the playmaker out there we know KD
can do it he just had seven in the last
game
will can see him going to go get it
again all right well I'll see you I see
you with your player props if y'all
don't know now you know my man will when
it comes to these player props
he is he's right he's right about it
he's usually right than wrong so uh will
you gave us two you gave us two you got
four more to go talk to me talk to the
people what are we thinking with this
next Pig
sadly we gonna be with the bulls all
right Zach Levine over 23 and a half
points like I think this is going to be
a very very high scoring game let's be
real Kyrie Irving I don't think anybody
on the Bulls I mean well about that on
the Nets can't really guard Zach Levine
I'm not gonna lie you know he's a high
value player he's going to get a chance
to put up a lot of shots he is going to
make a lot of shots tonight especially
from three the Nets look they're not the
best defensively I think they're
actually one of the highest teams that
give up the most points per game and you
know I fully expect that to carry on
tonight especially without Ben Simmons
who I think is our best defensive player
but look 23 and a half points Zach
Levine I'm definitely taking that and I
think that the main attention is is
going to be on DeMar DeRozan you kind of
see Zach Levine usually take that step
back when DeMar DeRozan is playing so I
think you know more attention is going
to be on DeRozan
there it is time time time all right all
right so you're a realist you're a
realist and you you not only a Brooklyn
Nets fan we know that we can see that in
the in the background you got the the
the sweatshirt on uh up underneath the
lock is the Brooklyn Nets logo so we do
know that you're a Brooklyn Nets fan but
you can keep it real you can keep it
real and say that Zach Levine is gonna
go over 23 and a half points I love it I
absolutely love it now let's go to your
next pick will you gave us three you got
three more 45 seconds is back on the
clock
talk to me
Greg you may not like this one Kyle
Lowry 12 points basically manly I don't
even gotta say the 11 and a half 12
points Kyle Lowry is definitely gonna
get 12 points come on man look your
Golden State Warriors bro y'all give up
the most points per game I don't know
what's happened to y'all defensively you
know Andrew Wiggins now looking like
what he was looking like last year
Draymond Green I don't even want to get
started on him but he did score 12
points I think against you guys the
other day actually when you guys played
the Miami Heat I fully expect that to
continue you know I think that you guys
defensive leaders are not that good I
don't think that Klay Thompson is what
he used to be I want to hear none of his
two-way player stuff and I think that
Steph Curry also isn't going to really
have an answer for Kyle Lowry as well so
I expect this again to be another high
scoring game but I think that Kyle Lowry
will cover this definitely 12 points fat
so you left three seconds on the clock
two seconds it was pretty short you know
I didn't you know like my main thing is
defensively the Warriors are in it and
Kyle already covered it last time that's
enough that's enough talk that's enough
talk because uh I don't know if you saw
but uh the Warriors won the championship
last year and uh
it's only a couple games in man it's
only been a couple games and they will
start gelling Andrew Wiggins is better
than he was last year I would say he
took the step up to become that second
best player for that Warriors team but
it's okay this is Yoshi this is your
time to shine you going with good Kyle
Lowry over 11 and a half he just had it
the other day so you can see him doing
it again okay I like your bet but the
stuff you said about the Warriors I I
don't know about that let's bring back
in producer Ryan producer Ryan
how are we feeling what's the chat
talking about
and sorry I had to kick you off last
time like that bro but you know we have
to move on no it's okay it was getting
disrespectful I I get it uh we'll go
we'll go quick here we'll go one uh and
then we'll get to the rest of Will's
picks this is getting juicy Adam lefko
jumps into the chat said let's go Lock
And if you don't know this about Adam
lefko the man loves betting quarters in
the NBA he says Sons to win the third
quarter tonight so Sons third quarter
money line
what do you guys think
Adam levko son's third quarter money
line if Left Coast riding I'll ride with
left go
who am I to question it
that's all right with left quote hey who
are you to question it but you know what
we're gonna finish your six picks bro
you got four down two more to go I hope
you're not questioning these picks will
because we we we trying to follow you to
the money man so I hope you're not
questioning these and I hope you real
confident 45 seconds is back on the
clock four down two more to go let's get
it will
damn another pick you're not gonna
really like yo I'm not really feeling
the Warriors tonight so we back with the
Miami Heats Jimmy Butler over four and a
half assists now look real quick let's
just start off with this that right here
the Warriors give up the fourth most
assists in the NBA this season again you
know talking about that defensive
presence on top of that Jimmy Butler is
a big game player man I think you know
you kind of see him slack off in some of
these games but when it comes to playing
other good teams Jimmy Butler usually
steps up his game you know they don't
call him Jimmy buckets for no reason and
we're not even talking about points I
think he'll get it done there too but I
do think you know to me he is the main
ball facilitator uh on that Miami Heat
team and I think that he'll definitely
be able to get five assists I think you
know him playing with bam again I
already think that Kyle Larry is going
to go off for his 12 points I think you
know bam Tyler Hero's been stepping up
this season so I can definitely see
Butler getting those five assists
I don't dislike it actually I don't
dislike it Jimmy buckets whatever you
want to call him Jimmy Butler he is a
playmaker he's a baller and he's a dog I
would say Jimmy Butler is a dog one of
the dogs in this league uh over four and
a half says he can go get that Warrior
to still win I hope you know what
happened the last time they played that
Miami Heat team
and it wasn't too long ago I just wanna
I just want to make sure that's vividly
in your memory will cause you was you
know he was doing some chirping but
that's okay that is okay I like your
pick though I do like to pick all right
five down five down one more to go 45
seconds is on the clock we'll take it
away
all right man look last pick we going
with the Timberwolves plus three and a
half and yo actually Greg yo just for
you bro just for the show at the right
on this cardboard man I don't even have
no more paper I was like we're gonna put
it on the back of the paper now you're
like going to Timberwolves here I
actually think that the Timberwolves are
gonna beat the sun's hair I think that
the sun's missing DeAndre and it's gonna
be a big loss for them I think that the
Timberwolf strength is that front Court
Rudy gobert and cat so not having
DeAndre and that's really going to
affect them and I don't really
understand why the money line is plus
three and a half because I think that
the Timberwolves should be the favorites
here especially because they don't
really have any injuries they're going
to be full strength and the Phoenix Suns
are not I think the Phoenix Suns are a
bit overrated and I just think that you
know that uh that the Timberwolves are
gonna be able to get it done you know
I'm liking Anthony Edwards I'm liking uh
Rudy go bear cat D'Angelo Russell I'm a
big believer uh give me the Timberwolves
at three and a half there it is will
lock alert lock alert lock alert I need
lock Alert in the comments what the
alert emoji lock Alert in the comments
what the alert Emoji Minnesota plus
three and a half no DeAndre ayton that
front court that they got
will you might be on to something let's
bring in producer Ryan producer Ryan you
are our chat Whisperer what are the chat
what is the chat
talking about right now well Greg we
mentioned before that what we look for
on this show is scoops
that's all we look for I got Scoops uh
lefco jumped back in the chat said the
head ref of Miami golden state is Bill
Kennedy the over is 5-0 when he's the
head guy he's not done the head wrap of
OKC Orlando is James Capers home teams
are 5-0 against the spread when he's the
head guy
levco we got ref stats in here wow I
mean I never even seen Russ Brads before
I only like where you find that at they
exist who knows yeah that's some Scoops
if I ever seen it uh but we've got the
Ian Evans jumping in here saying Kevin
Durant over 45 and a half points
rebounds assists
okay well okay well the next the next
Guru the Nets Whisperer
yo look I like that and tell him I'm
gonna make a call to my boy KD we gonna
get that done for you bro but I like
that all right you got Katie on speed
dial yeah I was about to say like man
hey look look you know like when things
are not going right just don't have to
make some calls yeah no I feel that uh
Michael bowling jumping in here saying I
will Hammer the Wolves for will tonight
uh and Sharma Sons minus four bro best
team right now so we've got yeah
Ryan uh I mean like Sun's minus four but
I'm not gonna disrespect will like that
you know
no disrespect on this side uh hey let's
move on though guys let's move on
because you guys see where it says
coming up Greg's pick up top
it's time it is time keep dropping your
locks in the chat me and my boy Ryan
before the show I was looking at some
player combos earlier actually Ryan pull
up FanDuel please
now this one that I'm about to talk
about this one's been dancing literally
all day long there's been a lot of news
surrounding the Brooklyn Nets today and
so this line been moving it started off
at plus 680. the Nash news came out and
it went to plus 290. now it's sitting at
plus 300
before I get to my pick they held up all
players meeting not too long ago well
you know about this Ben Simmons talked
about it Katie talked about it last
night KD came out and bought
he came out and bought after that
player's only meeting Steve Nash is gone
this line moved for a reason Katie's
going to be free he's going to probably
be out there playing like how he was in
Golden State being that all around Kevin
Durant player
so with that being said
can you please do the honors and click
Kevin Durant Double-Double Brooklyn Nets
to win I like this one but I don't know
if this is the way to go I need you guys
to let me know the line's been moving
the Sharks must have been taking it
something's been going on in Vegas is
this the BET to take Kevin Durant
Double-Double they just had that meeting
will they just had it not too long ago
you know he's gonna come out there on a
Vengeance do you like this one
Greg man Greg Greg I see I'm heartbroken
here man because you know my heart's
telling me yes
but the smart person in me saying I
can't see Kevin Durant getting uh double
double tonight I think that he will
finish with a high amount of assistant
points but double double
you got him going over six and a half
assists you don't think he's gonna go
get three more to get the double double
ah man I don't know bro like it's It's
Tricky It's Tricky I think that all
depends on Kyrie Irving I tell you what
if Kyrie Irving and if everybody else is
hitting these shots then I think that
you wanted something so I think you
definitely got a chance there but I'm
just a little iffy on it though rebounds
Katie you can go grab a couple rebounds
man he's out there on the Avengers I can
see it Ryan what are what are they
talking about in the chat I just love
how we all have our own bets tonight but
they're not really all like aligned with
each other we're all kind of like
battling each other here
um mackin's saying I got KD dropping 50
tonight trust me it's free uh K James KD
and Kyrie 30 each uh bagel and lox
jumping in and supporting will give me
wolves alt line minus 12. so T wolves in
a route
um
yeah that that's got to be juicy uh
considering they're three and a half
Point dogs uh ball talk Louie cam
Johnson 12 plus and the Suns to win plus
122 on FanDuel
there's some juice there
um and then Bama guy Warriors money line
easy money
like the Warriors money line play like
that a lot let's talk
let's talk Ryan hold on the squad at BR
betting also built the same game parlay
so let's talk same game parlay Ryan pull
up the odds for us so we can talk
same game parlay yeah so we've been
doing the show for a few weeks this this
may be my favorite same game parlor
we've put together mainly because look
at the headline the Bulls to win Bulls
money line
Kevin Durant 25 plus points DeMar
DeRozan 25 plus points Levine three plus
made threes you click this bet now boom
it shows up here
I mean the Bulls are gonna route the
Nets tonight guys and it's plus 703
what's better than this what's better
than this
what do you guys I love this I love this
so we got the Bulls Kevin Durant over 25
plus points DeMar DeRozan same thing 25
plus points in Zach Levine three plus
made threes we will
I know you feel some type of way about
this
yeah look y'all had me y'all had me
until it was Bull's money line parlay is
garbage I'm not gonna hit come on I
don't know who made that like what's
going on here like so like we trying to
win money here but you talking about
bulls money line you know you got Ryan
talking about the Bulls gonna route the
Nets what so I have to fall asleep real
quick like whenever I hear nonsense I
just get tired so if if Bull's money
line wasn't in there you would like the
rest of this parlay
yes yes yes I think everything else is
very doable yeah 25 for Katie is money
25 for DeMar DeRozan should be money and
three plus threes for Zach Levine um
my man basically just wants to mix the
bulls with the Nets and then run the
parlay is that what you're saying will
I think I might have to hit a reverse
parlay for you guys man
we also got a boost though Ryan for
Devin Booker and Anthony
Edwards to go
uh yeah there it is it's actually on the
screen there it is Booker and Anthony
Edwards to score 50 plus points combined
sitting at plus one ten
you guys like this one will
right yeah I'm liking that I'm liking
that it's a nice boost right there
yes the two best scores in that game
absolutely yeah
I like that one a lot too plus 110 go
get your money all right you guys have
been talking in the chat about me and
Will's bets it's our turn to return some
of that favor it's time for us to grade
some of your bits first off my man Adam
lefko been in the comments giving us
Scoops something that we love here we
love those Scoops but my man went into
his referee encyclopedia
my man was giving us Scoops about
referees guys this is the type of Scoops
that we need this is what we want to
grade we're trying to get deep in our
bed Adam levko got deep in his Scoops
back that's the type of Vibes that's the
type of energy that we need Ryan
are there any bets out there that we can
grade yeah so let's do uh let's start
off with K streets who says Bulls Nets
over and let me pull up what the number
is so because you know that would be too
hard to ask them to put the number in
here 232 over 232. what do you guys
think hey will you said it was going to
be a high scoring game earlier on in on
the show
yeah yeah I like that I like that
especially you know no Ben Simmons there
so I think that the Bulls are gonna be
able to attack the next but I think
that's just score more points so I'm
liking that over
I like that over too I like the over two
I think it's going to be up and down
Steve Nash is not there I think this
next team is going to be flowing today
and they're going to be flowing uh free
of mine
it's going to go out there and fall I
think KD goes off today can I can I get
a letter grade from each of you
a plus b
B
you see I'm I mean I'm a I'm a better
grader I'm good at a minus more generous
there you go two more dangerous
everyone's passing your class uh junior
says Zach Levine over two and a half
threes
oh it's a part of the it's a leg in the
parlay
it is
I don't know uh my man Zach Levine
over two and a half the the parlay is
three and a half I think I'm gonna get
I'm gonna give this one a c plus let me
get this one a c plus
Zach Levine I don't know he's just he
got to go do it he got to go do it gotta
go execute it
so C plus because I think I could have
I think I get out of B I think Zach
Levine could definitely uh hit that you
know he's got to get hot
okay uh we've got n Sharma back in here
Nikola vuchevich over one and a half
threes
I like Oh I like that too let me get out
of B plus
actually
that's actually doable and he he shoots
him make him yeah
man great
brought him out there Greg you jumping
in here saying you love that and then
you give it a B plus
that's not good enough
dude solid bro
dude I go home and show my parents a B
plus I'm in trouble come on now you say
you love something it's got to be an a I
go home and get my mom a B plus she's
taking me out for food like no Break My
Lying especially that's going on the
fridge yeah especially you're mad bro
shoot I might get because she was buying
me PlayStation games for bringing home
I yeah I don't know man my parents were
strict uh EV all right what's with these
e-v-i-e-e-v Andrew Wiggins over 15 and a
half points some of these usernames man
what are we doing over you love at your
Wiggins you love it that's the a that's
the a
two-way he only get with the a because
that's a Warriors player man look that's
a B minus that's a B minus
ah look Jimmy Butler's gonna be on him I
don't know it's gonna be a little tricky
but he could definitely get that though
but I'm not loving it though I like I
wouldn't like that in
he was just averaging like 22 this
season guess he had a bad game or
something he's averaging 17 now he's
gonna get 15.
I knew I could squeeze an a out of you
man I just had to find the Andrew
Wiggins prop that was it I knew I could
do it uh we wanted Scoops ball talk
Louie says uh Zach Levine has yet to go
under two made threes this season so
that's what we're talking about yeah I
mean we were talking about over two and
a half threes that's a good Scoop uh
this one okay this one's insane but I'm
gonna read it because it's insane uh
gang Dows Chris Paul 15 points 15 plus
points and 15 plus assists
oh I would love to know those odds I
mean you probably don't know those Ryan
uh give me a second give me a second
but no I'm not man you right away
those are to be high I'm sure right 15
assists is crazy
value value play I probably won't play
it I just want to know those odds
because that's very very intriguing
that's a value play for sure okay so I
have I have the odds uh pulled up here
so you can't do 15 plus assist you could
do 14 plus assists on FanDuel
if you parlay those two together it's
Plus 881.
it's not big enough for me I agree I
thought it was going to be higher than
that yeah I thought it was going to be
something crazy something that like
that'll make you think and be like oh
you know I could put ten dollars on this
yeah yeah not like as great as Chris
Paul is point guard all that I could
never bet somebody to hit 15 assists
like like I just don't even feel right
to me I'm gonna have to give that pick a
d
yeah I I agree unless it is like like
Greg is saying unless it's an insane
number where I could like sprinkle on it
and still feel good about it then yeah
no uh all right so we're gonna do one
more here uh I think I think I'm Big
Mike says Royce O'Neal over one and a
half threes thank me later
are we going to be thanking him now
though
what do you guys think I'm gonna give
him a b I'm thanking you now Royce or no
can go get it done
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to give that a
I'm gonna have to get out of C plus
there it is there it is hey
my name is Greg ivory
that's will Greggs and that is producer
Ryan
we had a really good show guys will you
came in here and dropped some of those
prop locks producer Ryan you are our
chat Whisperer
and I gave y'all that KD double double
y'all let me know is that a lock
or is it not think about it but we
we out
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]